confiné devant l'athénée en moyenne en
mars 2020 nous avons fait chaque jour
4h29 devant la télé un record presque de
quoi faire oublier la concurrence des
plateformes de vidéo à la demande
comme quoi les français restent fidèles
au poste
la regarder volontiers la télévision si
vous ne l'aviez pas elle vous manquerait
pourtant fut entend quasiment personne
n'était équipé en 1953 par exemple pour
voir le couronnement de la reine
elizabeth ii
il fallait aller dans la rue comme la
devant les locaux du journal france soir
le téléviseur s'installe peu à peu dans
nos salons 1% des ménages étaient
équipés en 1950 dit pourtant en 1959 60
2% 1968 plus de la moitié de nos
habitations
à quelle occasion avez-vous acheté pour
voir les chanteurs les la coupe du monde
de football et a pu sortir avec trop
vieux à mesure que les français
s'équipent l'offre s'enrichit les années
soixante dix fois le passage à la
couleur et l'apparition d'une troisième
chaîne au total en 1975 la télé
française rassemble 45 millions de
téléspectateurs quotidiens avec un
programme plébiscité plus que les autres
le journal télévisé
je m'estime bien informée
je trouve formidable de pouvoir
rapidement voir la main de mao
les hommes marché sur la lune jeter sa
formidable six chaînes dont les années
94 dans les années 2000 avec la tnt et
avec les box internet les chaînes et
bouquets payants se développe
aujourd'hui 94 % des ménages français
ont la télévision en 2019 selon une
étude du centre d'observation de la
société
60% des français regardent des
programmes à la télé au moins quatre
soirs par semaine
[Musique]